[Music]
china has changed profoundly
in the past four years under its leader
xi jinping
the country took a hard authoritarian
turn
presidential term limits were abolished
control tightened
sitting being as we all know he's going
to stay in power beyond 20 23
so for a longer period of time than his
predecessors
and no one is in a position to challenge
him
from the south china sea to the border
with india
china's military grew more assertive
especially towards taiwan
the democratic island the china claims
as part of its territory
i think xi jinping's once from jobiden
to
go back to the obama administration's
policy
to put it simply put pressure on taiwan
during his campaign for the presidency
biden refrained from naming china as
america's enemy
labeling it instead a strategic
competitor
just as the trump administration had
biden has boasted
he knows she better than any other world
leader having met him frequently
when both were vice presidents but he's
also promised
to be tougher on china than president
donald trump
he embraces guys like the thugs like
in north korea and and and the chinese
president
analysts predict that many of trump's
china policies
will likely remain including tariffs on
chinese
imports so prospects of a reset in
sino-us ties seem
unlikely in the short term they're
not great neither side
wants a reset frankly and the other
factor is
is that nothing in what the us's
early signals that they're giving
through biden and his staff
shows that they're particularly pushing
for a reset
the new us president says human rights
will be a foreign policy priority
last august his team accused china of
genocide
against ethnic uighurs in the far
western region of xinjiang
another likely point of friction the
intensifying clampdown on descent
in hong kong for china's leaders the
past four years
represent the lowest point in relations
in decades
to improve them will require significant
goodwill
from both sides but president xi's hands
may be tied
this year marks the 100th anniversary of
the founding of china's communist party
when members will be celebrating the
party's achievements
and that may include standing up to the
united states
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong